accompagne russe de frappe massive de la
Russie sur l'Ukraine se poursuit
conséquence je vous le disais de très
nombreuses coupures d'électricité et
d'eau dans de nombreuses localités à
commencer par la capitale Kiev le
président ukrainien volodomir Zelinski a
dénoncé hier des crimes contre
l'humanité il s'exprimait par
visioconférence devant le Conseil de
sécurité de l'ONU l'objectif de la
Russie semble clair désespéré la
population
ukrainienne écoutée les précisions de
notre envoyé spécial à Odessa Taline
là où je me trouve au dessin nous sommes
toujours sans électricité la connexion
internet fonctionne très mal pourquoi
vous m'entendez à travers le téléphone
et non à travers la caméra mais certains
quartiers de la ville semble commencer à
être réalimenté ça a été aussi le cas à
lui et qui Ève des travaux entreprise
hier soir ont permis de ramener
l'électricité sur la rive droite de la
capitale mais hier soir les coupures
d'électricité elles ont vraiment été
massives presque tout le pays ça pouvait
plonger dans le noir et dans le froid ce
sont en grande partie des coupures
d'urgence en fait qui ont été mises en
place pour certains endroits essentiels
comme les hôpitaux par exemple
fonctionner 3 centrales nucléaires en
temporaire
et la plupart des centrales thermiques
et hydroélectriques ont été à la
réussite le mercredi aura donc été
marqué par la dernière grande vague de
tir de mystérus ils disent encore
massivement les infrastructures
énergétiques